what if i told you the pandemic covet
made everybody lazier including maybe
you and maybe your competitors and how
this could be an edge for you if you
make the right adjustments so by the way
if i make my argument and it makes sense
to give it a thumbs up and subscribe to
the channel so let me get into my
argument here so let's go pre-covid
let's go covet and let's go post kobe
like kind of like where we are right now
so pre-covert pre-covet if i wanted to
sell you we met up somewhere if i wanted
to
sell you a product i flew out to you i
came to your office i came to your house
and if i'm a player like i'm the best of
the best maybe i earned the right for
you to come to me and then we go to
pandemic everything's shut down maybe
you're in new york or l.a or uk or
london or whoever you are right chicago
and things have shut down everything
went from face to face to what hey since
we can't do that why don't we zoom okay
i'll see you on the zoom and we saw each
other on a zoom right oh let me tell you
about what we do with our business
segment let me show you the screen let
me share this screen let me share this
screen here's our deck here's our
powerpoint here's our presentation oh
okay and now we're leaving the pandemic
so what are you doing now are you still
saying let me meet you on the zoo let me
meet you on the zoom let me meet you on
the zoom let me meet you on the zoom
okay
so during pandemic a lot of people made
a lot of money but a few people made a
lot of money and i'm talking a lot of
money i want to share a couple stories
with you so hopefully you can process
this for your own self so
in the investment banking world where
you are raising capital i meet with
investment bankers and big banks to
raise money whatever the money may be
right so
i would have
meetings with different investment
bankers
50 of these private equity firms weren't
willing to meet with you face-to-face it
was all zoom but the ones that i could
meet with they would not only fly out to
meet with you but we would have dinner
afterwards so imagine i got four options
here four options here between these
four eight options that they had these
four only wanted to do zoom there's zero
relationship built afterwards because
nobody goes to an italian restaurant and
says hey why don't you go to an italian
restaurant in new york i go to an
italian restaurant in dallas or in
florida and while i'm eating let's talk
to each other tell me about your wife
and kids okay great wife let me send
this link to my it's kind of weird ain't
it okay versus these guys they got no
business from me but these guys who flew
out and met face to face kneecap to
kneecap we went to dinner
by the time i said you're like i just
like this guy because half of doing
business is what liking somebody fyi do
you know how many people i did business
with said the reason why goldman sachs
had an edge over their competitors
because david solomon told his guys hey
you guys got to go meet with the clients
and other banks and private equity and
all these other places said no no no no
no strict guidelines zoom only okay so
now we're not here
some companies are still using pandemic
as a guideline to say i only do zoom
those guys are going to get destroyed so
the argument then becomes well pat i
totally disagree with you because i can
do six meetings on zoom while you can
only do two or three face-to-face
meetings don't i have an edge over you
no you don't yes i do no you don't why
is that because the biggest deals are
done where on the golf course the
biggest deals are done during the dinner
the biggest deals are done at a game the
biggest deals are done face to face to
face and nothing's changed i can't shake
your hand right now through this try
shaking my hand can you put your hand
down can you feel my hand we can't shake
hands right watch this i'll give you a
completely different perspective on how
this applies to me
when we had 20 000 subscribers and i'm
looking at the marketplace on youtube we
got a hundred thousand twenty to a
hundred thousand subscribers i'm looking
at everybody on youtube i'm like oh my
god that guy started ten years before me
that guy's been around hall man how are
we gonna compete with all these guys
and everyone's going to their show
everyone's going to their show
everyone's flying out to their show i
can't compete with them but you know
what i could do what's that
what could be your edge you know what
i'm gonna do i'm gonna fly out to my
guests and i'm gonna do three interviews
in la then i'm gonna do four interviews
in new york then i'm gonna do three
interviews here so i can do ten
interviews in three days while my
competitor can only do one
i'm gonna go meet with people rather
than waiting for the guests to say i'll
be available in july i'll be available
in nine months i'll be available end of
the year no how about we come to you so
we started going to our guests you know
what started happening all of a sudden
100 000 subs quarter million subs half a
million million 2 million 3 million few
billion views online because we went to
people and now i'm in my podcast set
just this week we've had three
presidential candidates that show up
francis in ghana who is the champion
heavyweight champion of ufc you name
them one after another after another
after another after another showing up
here why because we finally earned the
right for people to show up but even
today i'm no longer doing the zoom
interviews of course if i do an
interview with putin on zoom i would do
it but the point is
everything is what
face to face so for you watching this
are you still kind of leaning on the
zoom covet pandemic behavior to say i'm
only doing meetings through zoom are you
back to face to face because if you're
not going back to face to face those who
do are going to take your lunch and
those customers are going to love them
more than doing business with you so
don't be the person that doesn't make
the adjustments on the right time and
you kind of delay it and everybody else
passes you especially by the guys that
are competing all the way at the top
make that decision for yourself early on
so if this made sense to you and the
argument's been made give it a thumbs up
and subscribe to the channel i got a
video i want you to watch it's a video i
did probably six years ago titled how to
improve your work ethic if you've never
watched this click on us to watch it
take care everybody bye
[Music]